hey yo yo this is dr. John de l'année
with Ramsey Network thank you so much
for watching the YouTube show it is
awesome
keep leaving your comments and keep
telling your friends the numbers are
just getting bigger and bigger and I'm
really grateful to each of you if you
have a mean comment to leave
seriously go to church so today we are
taking more emails from the ask John at
Ramsey solutions com Kanzi emails are
coming in actually from all over the
world and I'm really grateful for that
so next email up is Lloyd Lloyd's not a
real name Lloyd is a character when the
greatest movies ever made Dumb and
Dumber but we're gonna go to Lloyd today
backtrack to tears Lord I love it ok um
so here we go hello dr. John hello Lloyd
I need your advice I'm a 54 year old I
have a serious problem that I can't
control
I'm in debt and making payments I have a
terrible spending problem that I can't
control
I'm buying all kinds of stuff digital
baseball cards and physical autographed
baseball cards do we have digital
baseball cards that not kovat that is a
sign of the Apocalypse digital baseball
cards makes me so upset that I spend so
much money please help
thank you Thank You Lloyd for sending
your note in man there's a lot here but
I'm going to condense it down into one
easy solution okay you said you can't
control your spending you can't control
buying digital baseball cards sign
things you hate yourself for how you're
spending money here's the deal you can
control it you can you just got to
decide - so Lloyd say it with me you can
control it but you got to have help if
you're at a point where you say I cannot
control my spending it has become bigger
than me it's an addictive behavior I'm
addicted to making poor decisions I'm
addicted to spending too much then you
got an ecosystem issue right it's a
number one you got to admit that you got
a problem what you've done here and I
appreciate that but you got to find
somebody in your neck of the woods in
your world and your ecosystem and number
two
you you got to get a community around
you that can be a friend that can be a
spouse that can be a pastor that can be
a small group but it's got to be a group
of people that will hold you accountable
there will be a community that will help
you step in and make an ecosystem where
you can be successful so what's an
ecosystem where I can be successful that
sounds like academic nonsense jargon
here's what it means I mean you got to
give somebody else your debit card if I
don't know if you're married here if
you're married give your spouse your
debit card you can't control it you've
admitted you can't control it set
yourself up for success which means not
carrying around a loaded weapon which is
your debit card or if you're not married
get with a friend and review your
spending every single week look at your
bank records invite them over for a
drink have coffee before work and you're
gonna go down your bank records together
you're going to be accountable for the
purchases you're making that's creating
an ecosystem where you can be successful
if all else fails block the sights on
your websites turn off your computer I
don't care if you have to get rid of the
internet for a couple of months you've
got to do what you need to do to protect
your financial future and more
importantly protect you from you
addictions start out as annoying
behaviors they frustrate you then they
make you feel guilty and you should feel
guilty right you violated one your
values you did something you said I'm
not gonna do it again I'm not gonna do
again I'm gonna quit spending my money
like this I'm gonna quit smoking this
I'm not gonna cheat one more time then
they do it again then you do it again
and that's when you take that brick of
guilt and you just drop it in your
backpack and becomes a guilt of shame
and then it affects everything you do it
affects your financial future it affects
your relationships it affects the way
you see yourself in the mirror it
affects the way you relate to God or
whatever belief system you have it
affects everything you've admitted to me
and now to America that you got a
problem and it may not seem like a big
deal to you people watching this show
but when you look in the mirror
and you start checking those bank
statements and you realize I can't stop
whatever the behavior is it's this
feeling of powerlessness that's scary so
good for you Lord for saying something
about it get a community admit to them
that you got a problem and then take the
steps to set up an ecosystem where you
can be successful
you got this man you got this and I
can't wait to email me back in like 60
days
tell me how you're doing all right
brother you got this this is dr. John
Delaney with Ramsey Network don't forget
to subscribe to the show here shoot me
your emails at ask John at Ramsey
solutions calm and follow me at all of
the internets and i will talk to you
soon take care rock on